we're talking about Sarah Palin she has  captured the public imagination we're  talking about it because she's a  heartbeat away from a 200 year old man  who's running for president that's why  we're talking about the reason why  McCain picked Sarah was because she was  a star and once you once you picked a  star you have to take the good and the  bad with that because because she's on  every magazine cover she's gonna get  scrutinized more heavily than Joe Biden  in her home state but she has 60 percent  disapproval in the country now you know  I'm a mother and I'm a woman and I think  they'll should be readily apparent and I  do not think any skirt will do and I was  so offended by the choice of Sarah Palin  and I think McCain hooked his wagon to  Sarah Palin and then he hooked his wagon  to Joe the Plumber  neither one of the fictional characters  [Applause]